Ciao a tutti Sono Marco sgallorini Ho 18
anni e oggi voglio parlarvi della mia
passione Allora voglio iniziare comunque
leggendovi una frase che mi ha ispirato
molto che parla di Michael Jordan
Comunque penso tutti conosciate e diceva
la sera prima della gara 5 della finale
Michael Jordan mangia una pizza e si
becconi intossicazione alimentare voglio
comunque scendere in campo e in quella
partita Seguirò 40 punti facendo vincere
la sua squadra Io mi ripeto in questa
frase perché penso che sia l'espressione
più totale della passione e del doping
del campione Ovvero la voglia di giocare
ovvero che quella che lo porta a fare di
tutto piuttosto che rinunciare e perdere
quella partita e io giocare rugby da
quando sei anni e
ho avuto diverse esperienze comunque con
la nazionale under 18 e Quest'anno ho
iniziato con under 20
è importante Comunque quello che vi
voglio dire perché
quella la cosa più importante che vi può
aiutare sono le persone che avete
intorno perché quelli che vi circondano
sono coloro che vi aiuteranno davvero
Allora le persone esterne non sono tutti
uguali devi sapere le classificare
perché hai coloro che ti vogliono
aiutare veramente e coloro che comunque
vi vogliono stare intorno solo per dire
Guarda io conosco Marco gallorini ha
fatto questo questo e quest'altro però
non ti conosce davvero
la vita della terra è molto complicata
perché rischi di isolarti perché magari
il sabato sera ai amici ti dicono dai
andiamo a bere una birra insieme Usciamo
Andiamo a ballare facciamo Facciamo
festa facciamo finora tardi però te non
puoi rimanere fino a tardi fuori perché
sai che il giorno dopo la partita sai
che magari è una gara sai che comunque
di fare una trasferta lunga sai tante
cose che però alla fine non puoi fare e
sono delle rinunce che comunque ti
portano via tempo così ha con la sua
famiglia che con i tuoi amici io
personalmente ho dovuto fare tanti
rinunce perché comunque
magari la domenica devo andare a giocare
e il sabato sera non potevo fare non
potevo fare festa non potevo andare a
ballare non potevo fare tante cose però
sono felice di averlo fatto perché
comunque sono arrivata a un punto che mi
che mi che mi ha permesso di dire Sono a
un buon punto della mia passione ce la
sto quasi per fare
quando comunque parlando delle persone
di nuovo che ti circondano non devi
fasciarti la testa per una cosa che non
riesce a fare da solo poi farti aiutare
da altre persone che ti circondano molte
volte comunque gli amici che intorno ad
adolescente Come ho detto prima ti
devono darti una mano perché comunque
devono stare dietro devono capire le tue
necessità come te capisci le loro
Però come se sono davvero amici loro
capiscono e devono accettare anche i
tuoi limiti visto che tutte le persone
le hanno
detto questo Comunque bisogna essere
grati a se stessi per non avere mai
mollato nonostante le mille difficoltà e
come ad esempio stare dopo allenamento o
mangiare di corsa perché torni tardi e
devi agli allenamenti subito dopo e gli
occhi Comunque dopo mentre stai
studiando ti si chiudono sopra i libri e
tanti mille altre cose comunque ti
passano per la testa in quei momenti e
bisogna anche essere grati alle persone
che ci hanno aiutato senza essere loro
ingrati gli amici che come ho detto Gli
amici sono stati vicini la famiglia
qualsiasi persona ti sia stata intorno e
niente ragazzi Questo è la cosa più
importante che tu possa avere intorno
gli amici la famiglia come posso parlare
di mia madre mia madre comunque è stata
la prima persona che mi è stata intorno
perché comunque mi portai allenamenti
lavare vestiti col fango stava dietro
Comunque ai miei alle mie necessità
quando per esempio uscivo tardi di
allenamenti doveva aspettarmi fuori al
freddo e nonostante comunque abbia fatto
percorrere un sacco di 4 mesi in
macchina per portarmi alle partite alla
fine mi sono anche capirci qualche
regola del rugby
all'inizio quando Comunque ho iniziato a
giocare non era molto felice perché ho
iniziato a 6 anni ed è uno sport che
all'incirca fin da subito ti mette a
confronto con il contatto perché
comunque essendo uno sport di contatto
di combattimento c'è subito un contrasto
fisico fin dalla tenerità però
nonostante tutto io non ho mai non si
vede mordere e soprattutto anche devi
fare capire alle persone che ti
circondano che non è solo quello
poi vi posso parlare anche per esempio
dell'amicizia che ti circondano come io
vi posso per farvi un esempio vi parlerò
di un grande amico che al mio primo
esordio in nazionale in under 18 si è
fatto 5 ore di macchina soltanto per
venirmi a vedere e mi ha supportato lui
mi ha supportato da quando Comunque
avevo eravamo soltanto compagni di
squadra senza dicendo cosa faremo un
giorno ci riusciremo a giocare faremo
Comunque come il sogno di qualsiasi
bambino arrivare in nazionale e lui
comunque nonostante tutto mi è sempre
rimasto accanto è stato che la persona
che mi ha detto ce la puoi fare Ci io
credo in te o che nonostante tutte le
varie avversità che abbiamo avuto
insieme mi è stato intorno e mi ha detto
come stai interessandosi a me che è la
cosa più importante che non sono solo
non siamo solo persone che sono portate
per una passione ma siamo persone sono
Dopotutto non sono né atleti ma siamo
tutti persone e non dobbiamo limitarci
solo al fattore esterno ovvero che tutti
dobbiamo stare dietro
uno sport allo studio ai problemi
familiari siamo persone dobbiamo
chiederci tra di noi come stai Perché
comunque anche soltanto una pacca sulla
spalla può aiutare Chiunque ti sta
attorno
soprattutto in queste posizioni devi
rimanere con i piedi per terra perché
non sfociare in Nazioni di menefreghismo
o nella superbia Perché quando si trova
in queste situazioni
parecchie volte sei di esempio per altre
persone e non devi poi potresti
influenzare le loro azioni anche senza
volere Infatti
non devi fare non devi sentirti
influenzato o nervoso da queste
situazioni ma deve essere fiero e devi
comportarti nel modo più tranquillo
possibile per essere un esempio per loro
Per far sì che comunque il tuo modo di
fare il semplice tranquillo nonostante
tu debba fare cattivo gioco parecchie
volte a diverse avversità non vadano a
intaccare anche magari le persone che ti
stanno intorno in modo negativo
ma quello che comunque vi posso dire che
avere dei sogni a fare di tutti per
realizzarli e la sensazione più bella di
tutte ma allo stesso tempo crescere come
persona mentre percorri questo viaggio
l'ho ancora di più perché nonostante
tutte le cose pesanti le cose che ti
possono capitare sono cose che nel bene
e nel male ti formano e
stare da solo nel tempo può farti godere
il tempo che passerai con i tuoi cari
che hai già nel momento o che
arriveranno in futuro
[Applauso]